j'ai vraiment expérimenté le salon d'un
poster comme j'ai pris mes fonctions
interne en psychiatrie après six années
de médecine théorique parce que
quotidien d'un étudiant en médecine sur
les moments fille au milieu des chansons
paillardes c'est un peu rien à voir avec
avec celui d'un jeune interne qui entend
toute la journée
docteur docteur et qui se dit non mais
c'est moi le de terre maintenant donc
les syndromes de l'imposture c'est un
déficit particulier de confiance en soi
ou même quand on réussit on n'est pas
fier de soi au contraire on va minimiser
cette réussite on rumine on se demande
pourquoi on a accepté ce job
on cherche des excuses si jamais on sent
qu'on va être démasqué donc si un
dénigrement de soi une ode culpabilité
beaucoup de honte et d'anxiété
j'avais l'impression d'avoir traversé
toutes mes études de médecine en étant
passé au travers d'un filet en mangeant
gombe en louvoyant et par un mélange de
chance de hasard de travail
en tout cas pas du tout le mérite donc
les trois piliers un peu de du syndrome
d'imposture ce sont la peur de tromper
son monde
la peur au ventre d'être démasqué et le
fait d'attribuer ses succès ses
compétences à la chance au hasard ou
parce qu'on est sympa mais ce qui m'a
permis de m'en défaire quand j'étais en
interne ça vraiment été de déjà en
parler d'en rire un peu avec les
commentaires de tourner ça en dérision
ça va vraiment permis de désamorcer le
côté dramatique de sentir un poster et
puis enfin de décrire une bande dessinée
sur le sujet où je me suis amusé à en
rire et à prendre un peu de recul dès
qu'on en parle
comment par exemple pour les anxieux au
qu'on loupe à rendez-vous qu'on a peur
d'aller un rendez vous amoureux ou aller
à une promotion ou pour un nouveau job
guy qu'on en parle et qu'on commence à
mettre des mots sur
cette sentiment très désagréable on se
rend compte qu'on n'est pas tout seul et
tout de suite les gens ça libère la
parole
ah mais oui mais moi aussi je me suis
senti comme ça je me suis senti en
fraude j'étais pas sûr de moi
d'accord c'est le syndrome de
l'imposture et tout de suite on n'est
pas seul
[Musique]
commencé à questionner son récit
intérieur qui en général dur parce que
il est dû à des croyances limitantes
qu'on a un petit peu incorporé pendant
l'enfance
vous pouvez très bien tenir un journal
de bord et commencer à les identifier et
y apporter un peu de compassion secte et
vos réussites
ce n'est pas être prétentieuse ci est
factuel dressé une liste de vos exploits
et de vos victoires dans tous les
domaines
restez sur vos objectifs sans vous
comparer aux autres en arrêtant de
toujours vouloir plaire et s'ajuster au
regard de l'autre les hommes et les
femmes souffrent tous les deux du
syndrome d'imposture
parce que tous les deux ont pu
développer en enfance une faible estime
d'eux mêmes
donc ils sont égaux face à st en
revanche il reste que les femmes sont en
dehors de l'enfant sont conditionnées
par leur héritage historique avec le
poids la domination masculine mais aussi
l'héritage social éducatif culturel qui
ont créé des injonctions sociétal des
stéréotypes de genre qui deviennent des
schémas intériorisé pour les femmes il
faut être parfaite faut être humble faut
être prudente accommodante
il faut être mince mais pas trop mince
c'est un petit peu comme si la société
en fait leur envoyer un regard critique
et conditionnelle on n'est jamais assez
on a le sentiment de jamais pouvoir y
arriver on est inadéquate et ça ça
alimente et ça renforce le syndrome
d'imposture faut bien sûr prévention sa
confiance en soi et son syndrome mais
sans tomber dans l'injonction sociétal
du il faut avoir confiance en soi au
contraire il faut vous déculpabiliser
commencez à vous connaître à vous
accepter et à vous aimer un petit peu
plus chaque jour